[Music]
recently it became clear Michael Myers
will not teach us to feel this year
because Halloween kills has been
postponed to October 15 2021 to make
this horror message a little bit more
bearable for fans at first teaser was
released in addition John Carpenter the
director of the first Halloween movie
from 1978 revealed in an interview that
the number of deaths in the new movie
will be significantly higher than in its
predecessors he told indieWIRE that he
had never seen such a high number of
murders before and that the film will be
very intense and brutal we are already
excited and are already looking forward
to October 15 2021 almost a year has
passed since the release of Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood and fans are slowly
asking themselves with which film with a
star director Quentin Tarantino conclude
his lifework the Kill Bill actress
vivica a fox might have an answer to
this question because the actress of
Vernita green talked about the possible
sequel in a recent interview with NME
and even though she herself will
probably only be seen in flashbacks
she has suggestion who could take over
the role of her film daughter nici
namely spider-man homecoming actress
zendaya
it's still unclear if she can convince
Quentin Tarantino with her idea for
sequel because actress Fox makes no
secret that she doesn't refer to a
facial information but this is just her
own idea for Kill Bill three how likely
the realization of this project is can't
be foreseen yet but Tarantino already
revealed some time ago in the happy sad
confused podcast that if he would do
sequel to one of his earlier movies it
would be Kill Bill three what do you
think about the cast with his and die as
Nikki and uma Thurman in her starring
role as the bride can you imagine
exciting fights between the two or do
you see someone else in the role of
Nikki feel free to write it in the
comments it has been known for quite
some time the Disney Plus wants to
please the Star Wars fans with an Obi
Wan series as the website rlm now seems
to have found out from a reliable source
another Star Wars actor besides Ewan
McGregor will return to the camera
namely Hayden Christensen that 39 year
old hadn't appeared in the franchise
since Star Wars Episode three and as
they say he's not supposed to take on a
smaller role either but will
turnes anakin skywalker however since
the series will be said eight years
after Revenge of the Sith he will
probably be mainly seen of the Darth
Vader outfit the news about
Christensen's return should have been
announced at this year's Star Wars
Celebration which won't take place again
until 2022 due to the pandemic s lrm
suspects Disney is not expected to
announce it soon since the shooting is
not supposed to start until 2021 anyway
a new Star Wars movie by Taika Waititi
is still in the making but without an
official announcement all the more
reason for fans of the franchise to look
forward to the new animation series
called
that bad batch the plot is about the
elite troop of the Clone Army which
already Pierce in season seven of the
clone war series so it's also clear that
bat match ties in directly with the
Clone Wars the so called clone Force 99
consists of elite fighters each of them
is genetically modified by a mutation
hunter is the leader of the force and
can't perceive electromagnetic signals
crosshair is the sniper and can't see
extremely far wrecker as the name
suggests is the power pack of the trubin
is equipped with extreme physical
strength Tech is a bit more finely built
but is especially skilled with technical
equipment according to an official press
release from Disney in the trooper gone
dangerous mercenary missions in the time
after the Clone Wars had faced many
dangers Clone Wars maker and the
Mandalorian director Dave Filoni has
been engaged as executive producer while
author Jennifer Cabot will be
responsible for the script Star Wars the
bad batch is planned to be released in
Disney Plus in 2021 actually the
shooting of the Uncharted filming was
supposed to start in March however due
to the pandemic the project which had
been affected by several director
changes had to be put on hold like many
others Tom Holland who placed the
leading role as Nathan Drake shared the
first official picture of the start of
the shooting with a hashtag uncharted on
Instagram a few days ago so the endless
back-and-forth has now officially come
to an end because in the meantime it
wasn't clear if the film would be
realized at all the story revolves
around the young Nathan Drake and his
mentor Victor Sullivan embodied by Mark
Wahlberg Wahlberg announced sometime ago
that the movie will be a mix of Indiana
Jones and the Thomas Crown Affair so
mixture between adventure and heist
movie after several changes ruben
fleischer who's known for venom
Zombieland took over the director's
chair the release date of uncharted is
supposed to be July 16th 2021 and we are
curious of the shooting will go so
smoothly that the deadlines can be met
as variety and other use magazines
report the Batman will not only stand on
its own but mark the beginning of a new
DC Universe next to the blockbuster a DC
crime series by Sopranos maker Terrance
will be produced the name hasn't been
officially decided yet but the title
Gotham Central is currently in the news
in terms of content the main focus will
be on the vigilantes in Gotham City
which is why we can very well imagine
Jeffrey Wright's appearance as
Commissioner Gordon also the series is
supposed to more or less directly tie-in
with the Batman and not tell the story
of the boy or the teenager Bruce Wayne
like a 5 season series Gotham in view of
the engagement of Sopranos and bought
wok Empire maker Terence winter a less
overexcited performance than in the
Gotham series can be expected this
series will be featured on the upcoming
us streaming service HBO max but a
release date has not yet been set
[Music]